[Music]
an american pastor
has been receiving a bunch of attention
online after he spat in his hand and
then rubbed it onto the face of a
volunteering member of his congregation
to make a point about god yeah that's
this holy spirit
he embodied god
though because there's different types
of spits there's
uh porno spit the
right and then there's like the
oh
whoa
i wish i was a pimp and i had a homie
like gentleman like give me that tobacco
level and then i [ __ ] slap somebody
that's a pimp action yeah i think you
don't see it clearly yet
but you [ __ ]
oh
he got the boogers dude is that the oh
is that the holy spirit that's the holy
spirit yeah and this is where no
most people
would not face jesus anymore no
what most people would do
is turn
away yes run this is a bad example jesus
is not that spitball bro oh god oh you
got two
you gotta reload
oh
that's a lot
look my boy is tripping dude what i'm
telling you
be strong what i'm telling you
it's just as he's physically standing
here oh
knowing what's coming
oh no god's saying can you physically
and spiritually and emotionally be able
to stand we could just slap them i know
that's what getting the vision or
receiving it
might get nasty no
that's all one point just like that
receiving vision from god
might get nasty
you mean the king
god i just bought in crazy faith
i just bought my dream car now we're
gonna get to the wiping
[Music]
the responses of the people
what i'm telling you that's just
dripping off his face
it's how the people in your life will
react
there it is this guy
this guy murders people yo this pastor
is a murderer that is some [ __ ] man
jio's reaction right now that's not okay
crazy i could smell it i could feel oh
[ __ ] that is not in [ __ ] song of
solomon i feel like that's what people
saw when when we did just kidding party
challenges in gross things that actually
really was kind of [ __ ] up really that
was actually like yo what the [ __ ] is
the church element makes it way like if
that was just porn yeah it doesn't
matter but it's the fact that it's in
church and people the jackass skit it'd
be fine absolutely because jk party you
know what you're getting into like that
[ __ ] is just [ __ ] that was on jk
church
no [ __ ] jk church dude it's their
prank channel
that's precious gemstones right there
dude yeah for real dude
god that actually all made us like kind
of [ __ ] made me mad uncomfortable
yeah that was really gross actually i
thought it was quick like to it pow even
that's nasty but the build-up he like
interrupted his own speech
yeah why did he have to do that he
locked it up yeah
and then he had to like [ __ ] paint
the mona lisa on it and he was like [ __ ]
it yeah he went like this because at
first i'm like okay i can deal with that
but then he went like
i wanted his lips
oh imagine he did his lips
[Laughter]
honestly that might as well have been
next that was a crazy like i thought we
should have wet willied him
[Laughter]
he's like and it might get nasty
it could have been a million other
things what are people saying he could
have just read a [ __ ] scripture
people are saying frankly there must
have been an easier way to explain that
sometimes following the good word isn't
the easiest task in the world for a
believer like a slap brandon said that
that would have been i mean but maybe
that wouldn't have cut the you know the
the noise you know like okay
this did the job though knock them out
and we did the last week you know so
he's like he's brainstorming how he
could top last week's sermon yeah that's
true oh yeah maybe just incrementally
like he he sermoned himself into a
corner he's like [ __ ] man
i think the only thing that helps is
that
he looks very well put together you know
what i mean he looks like a guy that
like flosses he should go to jail that
guy should go to jail bro yeah yeah it's
still nasty as [ __ ] but it would have
been worse like if it was someone else
because if he looked homeless as [ __ ]
man like i don't know but if it was like
somebody who looked like they would do
it you maybe would accept it but when
it's somebody who doesn't look like they
would do it it's like maybe there's
something like really weird that's what
makes me uncomfortable is that it looks
like such a mosaic style church like it
looks all nice but if it was some like
village church you just go
it's the fact that like you you expect
people to be more sane than that yeah
like that is just like who's the poor
guy that agreed to do it yeah i do feel
like this dude spit probably smells like
mint versus someone like me it probably
smells like fish sauce so like
you know what i mean oh do we not care
that there's [ __ ] cove at times hello
but he got the holy spirit through the
spit so what's good that's one way to
get copic bro that's i guess that's
extra belief you guys are missing the
point man the preacher just wanted to
show you how you have to stand tall when
things are [ __ ] nasty you're right
and we missed the whole point we just
got focused on the spit but he still
became a victim of nastiness he didn't
even a volunteer he didn't even deflect
it like what the illustration's supposed
to give you he said uh he stated that
the responses
were exactly what believers can expect
when they truly follow the word which is
what ill a stinky face i i guess
whatever it is
is meant to cause any reaction is like
appropriate to the amount of reaction
that you would get for like it must work
for that church if that church is
getting that much tithe it looks like
they're doing pretty well like they got
money so maybe that's what people go to
see this guy's killing it and we're
talking about it right now so you know
it's one of those like kind of like any
price is good press type stuff right i
think this is how you get more buddhists
in the world yeah i think that guy
should be arrested for spinning in his
hand and rubbing another guy's face only
for that he should be arrested that's
assault bro you can't forget the part
where well he went oh yeah he was like
making a spectacle of it like all right
bro just get it over with i know i know
you're trying to send a message but you
shouldn't spit on someone's face like
that it's poor guys oh well he didn't
spit on his face he might as well have
spin on his hand yes and then he
caressed his face yeah rubbed it in and
all the crevasses and you know
boss that's how you say it
i don't think he went hard enough man
for bosses i think i was i think it was
two weeks so what would you do pastor
jeremiah joe i want a [ __ ] [ __ ] in my
hand
opened up his hat
smashed this [ __ ] head do you have
the [ __ ] ready
no i would just like [ __ ] on stage
drop a little log
okay that was like that like a rip it
out and then [ __ ] take off he was
wearing a hat right was he yeah i think
it looks like joe because it is joe it's
expected
[ __ ] rub that motherfucker's head and
then put the hat back
is the wild pastor yeah
first huh do you smash it on the hand
first i wouldn't i wouldn't have done
this i don't think he's uh you know i
like a glob of it like i think you could
just [ __ ] in your hand just have a
[ __ ] mountain of that [ __ ]
and just take off his hat and just smash
it and then you rub it on the head could
you massage it
massage the skin
same message when there's something that
you don't want uncomfortable that you
don't want to be in what did you just
say
that you don't want to be in
that's that's that's even funnier to
imagine
doing that but you're accompanied
verbalization so bad that it doesn't
merit getting [ __ ] on your head what's
he talking about what's the point what's
this guy saying
he's gonna put his [ __ ] on my head for
this
so like when life is like kind of like
you know it gets
harder
um i'm sure you put the [ __ ] on your
head
please put the monies in the basket
you know when she
[ __ ] she hits the fan bro
so are they doing anything to this
church or is like no no that's the
sermon it's accepted obviously you know
people online you know are definitely
throwing their opinions and obviously
being discussed by it giving other
criticisms but they this pastor stands
firm in belief of uh you know what his
message is and in fact the responses
that he's receiving from people is
validating his point i like this guy
yeah
because if we're like oh man that's
wrong like we're kind of like that same
nastiness that's going against
in essence i mean i see thee call me
nasty then i see the the idea
i don't necessarily
believe in the the way but would you do
it if you were a pastor what would you
do anthony that pastor anthony
if you know better yeah you guys are all
critics man i just critiqued that he
didn't go i'd probably just use my words
i'd probably just use a story or an
example or an analogy powerpoint kind of
[ __ ] up that you would use a story an
analogy like that
if you want to spin it i would get
arrested for that i should get arrested
of course you get arrested for that that
guy is actually right i take that back i
take everything back it just seems kind
of hilarious from a bible perspective
you got the book of job where this dude
went through all kinds of nasty and you
go no i think we should just show spit
i just on this guy
like let's not talk about real [ __ ] from
the bible that was a real biblical
reference too you talking about this in
the book of joe cause to me that's one
of the nasty [ __ ] in the bible that
you're like oh he went through some [ __ ]
i know that is how excited he's like i
know like that did it for me i was like
i'm convinced yup
he got boils
[Music]
you